i've
been reading the bible and praying which
is not something i was brought up to do
at all but then my mom
my mom had cancer and she became a
catholic and some weird very strange
things happened that made me even with a
more logical mind kind of question how i
was thinking and they all said you have
eight and a half months to 11 months and
there's nothing you can do about it and
then she became religious
while in the hospital
just like on the verge of death she goes
oh i'm gonna be better by my anniversary
with jordan august 18th like
specifically if she had to have another
surgery and then that surgery didn't
work and then three days after that
surgery everything just fixed itself
and it was august 18.
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
this week i have michaela peterson on
the show michaela has a very popular
podcast of her own called the michaela
peterson podcast she is an entrepreneur
she has lots of different products
coming out which you'll end up hearing
about in this episode her dad is jordan
peterson so for those of you out there
that remember i interviewed him a little
while back naturally michaela is
deep and fascinating like her dad and
we had a conversation that was more of a
conversation like we debated and talked
about things and perspectives and i
thought it was really fun sometimes the
interviews tend to be question and
answer and it was like we talked about
things for a while and i just thought
that that was really fun i've been kind
of craving someone that i can do that
with she has a special feature that she
does on some episodes called opposing
views so we talked about that we talked
about religion and spirituality and you
know how that all plays in and the
things that she's trying to call in with
it and she's super fascinating and i
recommend her podcast uh but in the
meantime please enjoy this one and of
course uh please hit the subscribe
button if you like this podcast or you
like any others so that you get a
notification when we have a new one drop
do you like being in the states
i really like it i really like nashville
yeah yeah it's a cool city i mean do you
like country music i love country music
i like
the vibe here is really calm compared to
toronto
so
it's lovely
that's good that's good
um well and you uh i'm i mean i think of
it like nashville is a place where i
feel like you get like a lot of
bachelorette parties there and bachelor
parties and you just turned 30. so did
you like explore the town for your 30th
birthday
i didn't actually i don't really
i think i partied so much i partied so
much from like the ages of i don't know
like 14 to 23 like
that
i don't know
i like being near people like you can
hear the they're called wu buses so
everyone going like whoo down broadway
and i'm right it's great so i like
hearing it but no i just like i went out
for dinner for my birthday and then
stayed in which was fantastic
that's awesome well um i don't feel like
i really have to ask what you ate
because you probably had steak or lamb
right
lamb yep
do you have a special place that you go
to where they don't do anything to the
meat and they keep things really simple
or is it pretty safe to order anywhere
no i usually have to call ahead to make
sure especially with lamb it's usually
marinated and then that'll give me
autoimmune symptoms but there's an
excellent restaurant called e3 chop
house in nashville and it just
everything in there is amazing it's
everybody's favorite restaurant and so
they're really good
from people with allergies yeah
okay well a little bit more like um
bigger question you're 30. i feel like
every decade you have a birthday my f
and i asked because my 40th is in a
couple months so like every 10 years i
feel like you know you have that sort of
reflection point so
did you have that for yourself and and
if you did like what do you look at at
30 years old and go man
i took a long time to learn this lesson
or wow you know i i didn't realize that
this was this way were there any big
hindsight moments of perspective
i think mostly i just felt relief for my
twenties being over i think it mostly
was like oh okay something new gonna
leave that period of time behind so i
think it was mostly relief and i don't
know i'm pretty happy right now like i'm
more comfortable with myself i was quite
ill during a large portion of my 20s so
that was a kind of write-off and then my
family was ill for like the last portion
and so this seems pretty like i'm pretty
happy it's like that can go we can never
return to that and then
i'm pretty happy going forward i'm
definitely more comfortable with who i
am i think and i don't i'm more
confident i guess
you know it takes you a while to learn
what you're capable of
and i think the last maybe five or six
years has really taught me that i'm
pretty a pretty competent person so i'm
feeling competent at the moment i guess
competent confident what gave you that
perception shift what did you look at
differently that you're like man i
i didn't realize i was so good at this
or i was
i've been
so i've been running my dad's brand
since 2018 kind of when he
shot
up i guess i don't know got popular
online went on tour and everything and
i've been taking care of like the
business and and the brand
and and pr and online products and at
the beginning i don't have a business
degree right i don't have a background
in in
anything business related so when i
first started there were a lot of talks
with lawyers and people with business
degrees about how to run things
and i always kind of thought
you know social media is i mean you know
you have a podcast but like social media
is a bit different you don't really get
a business degree and learn how to use
instagram or do online marketing right
so it took me years of listening to
people and thinking i'm not sure if
that's quite right
and then seeing that play through
and then being i guess
being right about some major decisions
and then when those stacked up
i guess i got more confident so it took
a while but after working with
lots and lots and lots of people
um
turns out
i'm well i guess i'm feeling pretty good
about myself at the moment but i'm
having a good time and business is going
well
and i think i have my head wrapped
around kind of having an online
business
now
did the stuff that you learned with your
dad's business is is it are you using
that on yours and as that part of why
you
i'm kind of curious why you have a
podcast maybe that's the first question
is about the podcast and and why
well it started so
i didn't plan to have a podcast i had
this like i started in 2017
or 2016 just with a blog and i was just
writing down these weird food
experiments i was doing for my
autoimmune disorder
and so i started with the blog i got a
couple of podcast invitations from the
blog just to talk about diet things
really took off when joe rogan invited
me on to talk about the carnivore diet
but then i was kind of niched into being
a diet person and
i had zero interest in being a diet
person i was always like like
if there's anything well below zero
interest right i always kind of scoffed
at people who are gluten free and like
you just didn't take anybody who had
some sort of ideology surrounding diet
seriously
i was like yeah vegans you know
gluten-free people
i'm not one of them right and then this
autoimmune disorder
being
you know put into remission with this
ridiculous diet i was like okay well
that's
great for me i kind of feel like i have
to talk about that but i didn't want to
be niched in i certainly didn't want to
be a diet person forever and i
i think by the time i rolled around to
having my own podcast i'd been on a lot
of other people's podcasts and somebody
reached out and said oh i'll produce
your podcast like you'd be a good
podcast host i'll produce your podcast
just give it a shot and so i started
i started just kind of out of curiosity
and then
i thought i could use it to also
research some of my health issues to
talk to
you know have the ability to talk to
experts
which is an unbelievable
you know blessing just to be able to
reach out to people and talk to them so
i started it that way but then
i wasn't i'm not super interested in
you know i've kind of figured out my
health so i'm not really interested in
talking about health it was like okay
i'll delve into some other things and um
i started i've got this series and this
is what i find really interesting it's
opposing views
i'll have yeah i'm i really really
really like opposing views so one person
on
they're usually generally extremes
uh on a contentious issue you know like
an abortion you'd have someone who's
very very pro-choice and someone who's
very very pro-life
and then i'll have a conversation with
both of them and try and ask them
similar questions and try and stay in
the middle ground
and part of the reason i wanted to do
that was
because
i grew up kind of you know i went to an
art school i went to a couple of art
schools so i grew up in a really
more
liberal like very very liberal community
and then
my dad is more conservative and i was
like there's this huge bridge between
some of my friends and some of my
conservative liberal friends and some of
my conservative friends and you know the
other side it you can't just say oh well
the other side's crazy
right like
each side is crazy then
yeah everybody's crazy yeah exactly
exactly so
i don't know if that answers that's kind
of a roundabout way of answering your
question but i think i just started
started it because partly it was coveted
was isolating it's like i'm pretty
extroverted i wanted to talk to people
and then just see where it goes but the
podcast takes maybe 10 of my time like i
record a couple of times a week and then
most of the production the production is
outsourced
i have a social media person so what
takes up most of my time are
you know products and brand management
and pr and like legal
for my dad's brand so much bigger
it doesn't look like that on the outside
but oh no i mean i think your dad's
brand appear i mean it comes i mean
there's there's books there's tours
there's
interviews there's
i mean he's selling i mean doing your
personality test he has an online
lecture series that you can buy which i
did
um things like that so no it does seem
like a big business and um
but
so now i'm sure that there's there's
lots i agree i mean i do the podcast and
one comes out every week and i love
doing it but it's not necessarily a
super dominant thing in time i do i do a
lot of the research part of it like i
love learning about people before
um
i'm curious about having these opposing
views um because i've seen that with
your podcast and
i think it's a fascinating topic um too
and a way to present an idea
to people so what do you end up finding
in the end with most of these
interviews
that you sort of mediate between the two
because i'm guessing like they probably
go at it a little bit you pose questions
okay so they're actually i thought
having a debate actually i was just
stressed out about the idea of having a
debate and so how it's structured is
i'll talk to one person first
and then i'll separately talk to the
other person
so they don't get to communicate with
each other which makes yeah and so i've
got some criticisms like oh it'd be
better as a debate but
some of these arguments are so different
that i don't even think we could have a
useful conversation
like i don't think i could mediate
between these
so huh i mean yeah i feel like part of
my podcast and and what it's like in the
intro is that no matter who i talk to
you end up realizing that people are
more alike than they are different
and i think that you know that's i like
to highlight that show that and get into
a deep enough conversation where we get
to the point where it's like you know we
all kind of want the same thing i guess
i use you know you could use coveted
vaccines as an example like you get it
because you want to be healthy and you
don't get it because you want to be
healthy like we're more alike than we
are different and so i think it'd be
fascinating to have them like go head to
head because
you know it humanizes people and you
know just like you know in your
experience if you go head-to-head with
somebody like you both get humanized and
you know when you're face-to-face with
somebody even just like this um
you know you unders you know there's
more compassion
we'll see i'm gonna i'm really really
tempted to test it out i think it would
be entertaining but some of these like
some of these people
really hate each other right like even
the so pro-choice and pro-life
for example
it's interesting because they're both
arguing
to keep
they're arguing on behalf of someone
right they're both arguing on behalf of
somebody else
kind of but you too but it's their view
too
or they wouldn't be saying it
yeah this is true but i mean
i mean most of the arguments i think
i've seen are from a place of compassion
okay i did an immigration one right
and and the one the one guy who's
pro-immigration was like yeah it's great
for the economy you bring talented
people in everybody spends more money
right and it benefits society as a whole
and the person which that's a very
simplified you know description of what
he said but then the other guy
was like oh no if you bring immigrants
in then people who make less money
you know you're talking about seriously
low-income people then those people have
a harder time
finding jobs it's not the rich people
are the people with jobs that you really
have to worry about it's these people in
low-income neighborhoods that are
actually at risk
and so
usually i think after the opposing views
i come away thinking yeah they're both
kind of right like they're both kind of
right but they're not arguing about
exactly they're talking about two
different parts of the same argument
it's it's fascinating anyway i really
enjoy it
what do you because i know that uh one
of the things that you have confessed is
that you're kind of a contrarian you
love to
you know you're disagreeable um what is
it about it that fascinates you when
people don't agree or when you have
opposing views
i think it's because usually going into
those i'm you know more on one side of
it and i would say generally speaking
and probably side more with the
conservative initially like the idea i
have whatever the problem is
um i've noticed i probably have more of
a conservative idea
and then going into it i can
i'm not particularly i don't think i'm
particularly attached
to ideas i don't mind being wrong
right it doesn't you know i think i've
been wrong so many times that i don't
care anymore right it's probably part of
being open when you're open you're okay
with being wrong because that's it's
like part of the inherent nature of
being open yeah yeah exactly and it
doesn't matter right as long as you're
trying to figure out what's true
does it matter so are you
you're almost like the beta test for the
opposing views to be more on one side
generally but then in the end you end up
realizing that the other side isn't
wrong either like i think you're your
own beta test for how well it would go
if opposing views came together because
naturally there's probably a little bit
of contentiousness some sparks and then
essentially like it gets humanized yeah
this is true but then when you look at
youtube comments that's not what you get
you just get you know and i usually tell
people like just
try and be reasonable in the comments
because i'm trying to get people onto
the show so if
you know one side is just constantly
being more attacked then people are less
likely to say yes coming on because why
would anyone want to come onto a show
where they're just going to get attacked
right so like just keep it down
but uh people are people can be pretty
one-sided right and just not understand
the other side at all
so your hope would be that you'd listen
to it and go okay you know these are
both people and maybe
they both have points even though i
don't agree with all of them but i don't
know how
well the average person does that
otherwise i don't think we'd be in the
situation we're in with covid and with
politics that we are right now like
there's obviously some sort of gap
between people's ability to understand
the other side
what's the what's the disconnect i'm i'm
but naturally an open-minded person i
love to i don't mind being wrong either
if someone says something and i can
change my mind that's fine i actually
look at his progress like i can learn
and get smarter
um what what's the what's the what's the
what's the issue with people being so
hard-headed and have such cognitive
dissonance around issues like where does
that where does that come from and is it
something that actually needs to be
solved or not
um
did you ever do one of dad's
personalities tests i actually did
okay and is your openness like off the
charts yeah
yeah okay i'd have to look at the
percentage of what it was but
i don't know i i remember it being very
high
yeah so i i think
i think for more open people then they
can go either way and i think the
percentage of you know if you scored
like 85th or above or something like
ridiculously high
people who are at the 50th percentile
are so much lower than that i think it's
difficult to understand like um i know
the type of person i have a difficult
time understanding and it's someone who
doesn't really want to do things like
they'd rather stay home they're not as
interested in meeting new people right
they're not particularly interested in
ideas and i think the
if you just look at the personality
scale the average person
just isn't
that interested in changing your mind
right so so i don't and i don't even
think that's something you can learn so
i'm not even entirely sure how to fix
that problem right if it's not if it's
just kind of a human nature
as an average i don't know but i was
trying to with opposing views but i'm
not sure if it's working to be honest
it's entertaining either way i think
it's a great format and i love the idea
of them going head to head because i
think that like foundationally we're
more alike than we are different so i
think it would be really entertaining to
hear people go at it and then of course
like i think in the end everybody ends
up getting the same place you do where
you're like hmm they're not wrong either
and then you go like the truth is always
in the middle i mean even if you look at
politically like people usually want the
most democratic republican and most
republican democrat like people don't
actually generally really want the ends
of the spectrum they want somewhere in
the middle but yet we call it one thing
or another and when we name things it
can't be anything else yeah
i completely agree i don't know i'm
gonna like i said i'm going to try this
in person but
some of these people have spent their
entire lives arguing one point of view
right and they know each other right if
if all you do is focus on the
immigration one for example if all you
do is focus on how immigration is bad
you know everybody who's telling people
that immigration is good you know all of
them and you don't like them already
right
and so and even the when i had the
abortion opposing views like
they knew who each other were and they
didn't like it like so there's already
they've spent so much time focused on
one way of thinking
that putting that person in in the room
and trying to have a discussion with
someone who thinks the opposite way
would be interesting i don't know if it
would i don't know what would happen
i'll have to do it eventually just to
see
do you think that as a culture we are
continuing to become more and more
polarized
interviews i mean it looks that way
right but
is it productive yeah
well it's definitely not productive and
you can tell just by i mean i'm living
in nashville right nashville is pretty
conservative yeah i went i went to
and so i've and i've been to like
parties here or just talking to people
and they're pretty conservative so you
have people and they're like oh yeah you
know if
you know some of those covid bills or
like liberals come over here like we
have our guns like oh i was just going
to say they have guns and they hunt
yeah exactly and then you go to
you know areas in california and they're
like oh you know like rednecks
rednecks with guns like there's no they
you know they don't have any brains they
don't know what they're talking about
they just follow fake news right and
they just
i don't know how those
like i don't know how those type of
people can get along
yeah i just think it's getting worse i
think the polarization is getting worse
and it gets harder and harder for people
to hear each other
and be open-minded and i think a remedy
is
being able to have that conversation i
think your dad's gonna have them all in
the same room about that a time your dad
talks about being able to actually have
the conversation right it's like yeah
you got to be able to talk to each other
i don't know if i would know how to
navigate that what do you do when one
person starts like hammering it out at
the other on the other person you're
just like okay stop everybody breathe
take a breath take a breath guys get it
up stop talking stop talking this is
where your mom's tricks come in because
your mom's super spiritual and you're
like okay
everybody take your deep breaths
close your eyes yoga
yeah yoga breaths
right
right but i think it's fascinating i
think we're in a we're just like
cultures in this place that's not
getting seemingly not getting better
it's getting worse at least from um
you know polarized perspectives and um
division it's like you know
uh divide and conquer takes on a new
year like you'd say i used to think
divide and conquer was all about you
know uh divide up the work and we all
get done more done but divide and
conquer is far more about like when
people can't agree you actually suppress
the whole thing and then someone else
can be in charge
do you think things were getting better
before coven
hmm
not that it matters now but yeah i don't
i don't think so i think that it's
probably been
either
i think it's steady i don't think it was
better before co it was better than
before covid
but i think that also sometimes what
ends up having to happen is there has to
be like such a huge swing another
direction to kind of
get people to
take stock and have a look at everything
and you know when something is so in
your face you end up having to finally
look at it and make a decision for
yourself
and um so i think that and i i
personally think that we're being asked
to look within and use our own inner
guidance and our own
emotional body as more of an indicator
of truth versus you know the media
outlet or the newspaper or the
television program
or anything like that because
we're just having a hard time struggling
we're struggling with what's real and
what's not so
um but i don't think it was better
i i agree with what you said i think it
wasn't getting better
yeah okay from from my point of view for
that it at least in canada it looked
like
thing and that could have been because
of my dad and all the controversy that
happened with him in like 2016 2017 but
i thought like 2018 2019 i thought
things were kind of calming down like i
thought we were
hearing about less fewer problems but
then coveted skyrocketed everything
i think every four years we get a
problem you know every four years we get
the great divider right like the color
divider and you know people like tv gets
obnoxious and there's ads on tv all day
about your local government or your you
know or national government with the
president and you know
biden was a divider and trump was a
divider and you know like seemingly more
than normal
yeah
i think your point too about having to
look within kind of for guidance is a is
a smart
point because
i think people underestimate the value
of intuition
right and it like um i had a hard time
wrapping my
mind around intuition because
i always thought about things like
logically whatever that means right
whatever i could actually factually see
and then kind of balancing that out in
my head and then
even though i had this gut instinct most
the time where i was like okay logically
this makes sense but my god's like
pulling me in the other direction real
hard so what's what's going on there and
i think what happens is people are
really good at recognizing patterns that
they can't put into words
and so if you get this feeling where
you're like no something's off it's
because you've identified a whole bunch
of patterns out there
and you haven't
figured it out enough
i guess to put it into words uh
so i'd say intuition is definitely
i at least undervalued it and now that
i've been kind of going more off no no i
feel like like i'm sure this is right in
my body and i don't know if women are
better at that than men or if people
just
kind of i think i stuffed it down and
ignored it for a long time without
valuing it but my life's definitely been
going better since i started being like
no my gut's saying do this i'll just go
for it
that's good what are some what are some
experiences
where you look back and think if i would
have listened to this this would have
been different
relationships mostly i think
yeah being like you know i can't think
about it it doesn't make sense in my
head but it doesn't feel good and i
guess relationships are an easy thing to
point out because that's where you get a
lot of that instinct
but i'd say
probably relationships and then some
business
opportunities that i thought were a bad
idea that were
that i was like
but kind of maybe more pushed into
because there was no law i couldn't come
up with an explanation about why it was
a bad idea right like this just doesn't
feel right which is not a good argument
if you're if you're trying to make your
argument it's my intuition it's just not
a good argument especially if you're
talking to a man they're like um yeah
yeah see the numbers yeah yeah exactly
exactly and i'm generalizing like i
always feel like you know obviously i
had a very long conversation about
polarizing so we're kind of i'm using
generalities here but men tend to be a
little bit more analytical a little bit
more by the numbers a little bit more a
little bit more head space instead of
body and um and yeah i'm sure talking to
a guy and saying i don't know dude just
doesn't feel right let's say yeah do
this you know let's let's pull out
that doesn't go over well
yeah and i think i think the fact that
you know generally speaking men are well
at least known for being better you know
thinking about things in numbers like
that i think that's part of the reason i
kind of dampened down my feelings as
well
you know growing up and probably as a
in my 20s
which was you know my entire life so i'd
say early 20s but i probably
you know whenever i had this feeling i
was like well if i can't
put it into words it doesn't matter
and it took me until i i think i was 28
maybe
or maybe 27 27 or 28 before i was like
you know what that does matter and maybe
focusing on it will actually improve my
life because maybe
it was until i thought maybe i was
picking up on patterns that i recognized
but couldn't put into words and that's
what intuition is i don't even know if
that's right or not but
yeah i think the fact that that numbers
and thinking about things logically are
more is more associated with men made me
dampen down that kind of part of me
yeah i think patterns or frequency
i think of a lot of things in terms of
frequency
the old nikola tesla famous quote if you
want to know the secrets of the universe
think in terms of energy vibration and
frequency yeah yeah i've seen that okay
okay tell me what that means
just that everything is an energy like
we are an energy everything has an
energy and so
um and then understanding in quantum
physics we're not dealing with um the
things that can be seen and that
everything is connected and quantum
entanglement is the word for that
and that we can we also so we can really
feel things even though you can't see
the connection you're there's threads
connecting there's energetic connections
and that we're energy and so we're kind
of creating wave patterns and these wave
patterns interact interact with each
other
being other people
and so we're getting
feedback on our surrounding on our on on
what we're dealing with we're getting
feedback on that and i think that that
can happen at a distance or right next
to each other
um yeah because it's energetic and it's
all that quantum physics stuff that i'm
fascinated with but definitely don't
understand well enough
um but yeah i think you're right you're
picking up on patterns but because the
pattern could be a pattern of frequency
um okay i like that
i like that a lot i don't understand
that either but there's definitely
something to that because you have it
happens when you have conversations with
people too right you have a conversation
with something and something's just off
you're like this is off and nothing
seems to be going wrong but something is
not good here right and it and then you
can have a conversation with someone or
be near someone where it's like this is
comfortable
and i always was like maybe it's like
smell or i don't know what it is exactly
but
it's weird
where do you feel like you pick up more
of your nature your inherent nature and
we talked a little bit about parents but
like they're kind of the foundation for
all of our
all of our good and all of our bad and
all of our all of our own patterns um
are you more i'm guessing you're more
like your dad because you know from what
i understand about your mom and my
watching things and listening is that
she's pretty and
she's pretty into the spiritual
intuitive realm and
um and so you know being analytical is
not necessarily her nature so and i you
strike me as someone that's a little bit
more analytical
yeah i'd say probably
i think maybe the older i get the more
i recognize parts of my mom in me but
i'd say
yeah it is cool it is cool um but i'd
say probably like 70 percent dad like um
part of the reason
i've been running his business is
because when
when something's off i can you know i
can look at something and say this is
not gonna be okay with him right
this is not gonna be okay with him and
it's spot-on all the time and it's it's
anything from you know
business deals
to
thumbnails
or to how something's written right
um where i'm like that's off and he's
gonna pick up on that or that doesn't
sound right and it's gonna bug him it's
mostly that like that's gonna bug him
um
so i think that's why i got involved in
running his business
but like i said the older i get the more
i see parts of mom
and i think the more i value those parts
yeah
do you think that is because your dad
your dad's nature which is more dominant
in you at this point has been rewarded
in different ways that are more
quantifiable
probably
like probably i mean i was
you know and i think that's pretty
normal for getting rewarded for grades
and
and accomplishments that
yeah for sure that that's easier to
reward too
and that's always what i
and i don't know if that's how i was
brought up
or if that's just what i'm like but i
always thought that that was more
important you know whatever i can
accomplish whatever i can accomplish
you know look what i did type of thing
rather than
mom's side i don't know she's definitely
different than me like we don't think in
the same way
but
her way's definitely working for her
she seems pretty happy
she's just very content stable yeah
she's just unbelievable yeah content
she's just okay with things she goes
with the flow and she's you know if
things are happening i'd say she goes
with the flow
she goes in the flow way more than me
right if something's happening i'm like
nah this doesn't have to happen this way
like this can be changed a little bit
let's just you know
curve curve this problem into something
else and mom is kind of just like no if
it's happening it's meant to happen
right which i think is a much calmer way
to live
but i definitely don't do that allowing
is hard as hell yeah especially if it's
kind of blurry about if it's possible to
change it right if it's not possible
then i'm like okay if it's if i can't do
anything about it that's fine then right
i'm not gonna have an issue there
but if there's like a little bit that i
could do to change this then
i'm not that comfortable with just
sitting and i can't really see what
happens the whole eckhart tolle like be
here now like yeah present moment is
very freaking hard
because i feel and maybe you feel
similar
maybe
i don't do anything there you just live
hang on he's like and like when he talks
he's like okay just be present from now
until
now and you're like i did nothing during
that little second there that we waited
you know there's nothing happening in
that moment but i understand the value
of releasing the energy and releasing
things and not forcing and it's like
yeah how how do you well how what's your
decision-making process or your
discernment between
you know forcing things and having that
like well no we can do that better
versus more of mom's nature of allowing
and content and letting things go like
how do you look at that now because i
find this to be very hard like what do i
what do i effort for and knowing that
growth comes from effort and struggle i
mean i i do believe that too
yeah nothing you know nothing really
shifts and change unless there's real
pain in there yeah there has to be some
struggle but yet the the the word is
like be here now be present and let
everything go and you know don't force
things and don't effort it's like such a
hard conundrum
i have great difficulty with that i
would say i err on the
a side of just trying to you know make
things go in the direction i think they
should go
and i've gotten better
more recently
more recently
i've
been reading the bible and praying which
is not something i was brought up to do
at all
but then my mom
my mom had cancer and she became a
catholic during that period of time and
some weird very strange things happened
that made me even with a more logical
mind kind of question how i was thinking
so
she was well she was diagnosed with
cancer and we went to a whole bunch of
different specialists obviously all over
north america and they all said you have
eight and a half months to 11 months and
there's nothing you can do about it and
it was a very rare like
absurdly like you'd see in the movie
rare type of cancer where it's like oh
yeah 30 people have had this and they
all die it was like really she had to
get that one right so that happened that
was weird and that was after
you know my dad kind of sprung to fame
or whatever you want to call it so that
had we were already living in a place
that was weird
and then my mom got diagnosed um
incorrectly and then she got diagnosed
with the really bad one and then
over the summer
she had surgery and then the surgery
got botched and she got injured and then
that almost killed her and she was like
and then she became religious
while in the hospital
just like on the verge of death it was
awful
and
she goes oh i'm gonna be better by my
anniversary with jordan which is august
18th and it was like the beginning of
july
we were like okay
mom in a month
yeah like a month and a half right she's
like i'll be better august 18th like
specifically and we're like okay
and then
she got flown down to the stage and she
had to have another surgery and then
that surgery didn't work
and then three days after that surgery
everything just fixed itself
and it was august 18th
and my mom oh yeah and
my family we were just like
okay
that literally makes no sense right all
the doctors
had no idea why things just resolved and
my mom was like yeah i knew that was
going to happen right
and so after that i was like
that's pretty weird like that's pretty
weird maybe did she get an intuition
or did she manifest did she just decide
i'm going to be better by this day no it
was i think it was intuition like she
says it was god that's what she says
speaking
yeah there's like an intuition type of
thing right yeah
and so after that i was like okay well
that sounds pretty good like
whatever happened there i'm a fan of and
if and my mom's been she's right about
things a lot without being able to
explain them like when i was diagnosed
with arthritis when i was little she
really wanted me to look into diet and
we did right like i stopped eating sugar
which really didn't do anything like
at one point i cut out
just certain things because my mom was
like maybe this is fixable with diet and
my dad was always like no there's
absolutely no evidence that diet has
anything to do with autoimmunity
and so
and so did the doctors that's what the
doctor said so i kind of believed that
but then it turned out it was fixable
with diet even though the diet is
extreme
um
and there are a number of things that
have happened throughout my life where
my mom just ends up being right even
though she can't explain how she knows
so it's very frustrating for her because
it'll take 15 years and she'll have been
saying oh do this oh do this but
everyone's like well why
right and she can't explain why
and so that happens enough
that
well this thing happened
you know with her surgery and she was
like yeah you know god you know i've
been praying and and all these things
and
i was like okay well maybe this is one
of the one of those things where i just
don't understand and you were just
picking up on something that i don't
understand so i guess i kind of looked
around and talked to some people and
tried to figure out how i could
understand what was happening to her
and so since
something clicked in august something
clicked in august and i think my life
are you talking about for me for me yeah
something clicked in august where i
think
there were a whole bunch of really bad
things happening
um like my dad was really sick still and
it had been like a year and a half of
him being ill he was still really sick
in august
and i was going through a divorce
and then i had this business to run and
it was really stressful and
they were all tangled up with each other
and so there were it was four major
problems and i was so overwhelmed i
wasn't depressed or anything i was just
like this is not like i can't keep
living like this it's too
heavy
and
something clicked
in august where it was like
you know whatever it was it feels like
god revealed himself to me
and so
it seemed like the most logical
explanation for how weird life is
was god
which is still weird for me to say but
anyway to get back to your question
about how i handle
figuring out what i'm capable of
changing and what i'm not capable of
changing what i've been doing for the
last four months is
when i get to the point where i'm like
you know should i push further like am i
doing the wrong thing or is there more i
can do
to perfect whatever i'm working on or
you know countless examples um i pray
and wait
and that kind of i don't know what
happens i mean maybe god's answering my
prayers maybe it puts me in a state
where i'm calm
and can think clearly but having
something to go to to say
or maybe it's that i'm actually
outlining my problems and outlining what
i want
maybe it's that i'm being grateful like
i don't know what's going on but that's
allowed me to at least step back and
think
we'll step back and
well things seem to be working out
better so hooray for that
wow
thanks for sharing all that that was
that's i think it's i think it's
fascinating i think there are so many
people i i mean i i think everyone could
probably say they could they could be on
board with wanting to know
how to achieve the life that they want
yeah how to get the right information
and it might not be the same for
everyone it might not even be called the
same thing you know like your prayer
could be called
you know meditation for somebody you
know yeah um and it might not be
a god religion thing it might be a
spiritual thing it could be
many different things but i think
everybody's looking for
that sort of direction and answer have
you ever had any sort of mystical or
transcendental moments where you
experienced something that seemed like
it was
uh
other energy or or took you to another
place
yeah a lot
wow this is also a lot um
and there were logical explanations for
this too but at some point it i don't
know at some point when this kind of
thing happens so many times i don't know
if the logical explanation is actually
logical so when i
when i um first went into diet and put
myself into remission for the arthritis
and depression and chronic fatigue i
stopped taking all my medication
because
i was like i was angry too right at the
medical system that some of these things
were
preventable it was like okay well i'm
never taking any medication like ever
again unless you know
i absolutely need to because i'm gonna
die
right so i stopped taking everything and
i wanted to
this is before i knew that you couldn't
just stop taking antidepressants if
you'd been on them for a decade and a
half i went into because they said it
was dangerous because it's dangerous to
stop or yeah there are dependents
forming so if you're on a psych med and
this goes for any psych med um if you're
on a psych med for a long time
especially if you're on a high dose for
a long time
you have to wean off over like a period
of two years without so that your brain
can adapt to not using the medication
anymore so even if the depression
underlying depression is gone you can't
just stop the medication and
i don't know how well known it is that
things like ssris are they're not
addicting for a selective serotonin
reuptake inhibitor
so so it's it's the like one of the
typical antidepressants like paxil or
prozac or something okay okay but um
they
they change your brain slightly so they
accustomed to the drug just like if
you're on an opiate like a painkiller
right you can't just stop taking it you
have to wean down because your body
adjusts to it
and this
this isn't widely known i certainly
didn't know it
um so i ended up putting myself into
antidepressant withdrawal
and it was absolutely awful for about
two years because you just stopped
i stopped over a two week period okay
right and i i'd gotten off of oxycontin
when i had my hip and ankle replaced
from the arthritis
um i was on oxycontin for the pain and
so i was familiar with what that felt
like so when i stopped taking the
antidepressant and that didn't happen
like i wasn't sweating i wasn't nauseous
um i was like okay it's fine so i just
stopped taking it over two week period
and the antidepressant withdrawal didn't
hit for another two weeks
and so i didn't know what it was
and what happened was i
ended up having what the medical
community would call like visual
disturbances
but i full-on hallucinated periodically
for about a year
where it was like once a month i'd see
and what it looked like
this seems this seems insane just
talking about it so it makes me a bit
uncomfortable but what it looked like
was
i'd see faces or something demonic
and what i assumed that was was
i was in this like state of panic from
the antidepressant withdrawal and i
assumed my brain was just making up
making up things to
i don't know
yeah kind of support the panic i was
feeling yeah so it's like if you're
panicking like you're running away from
a wild animal
and you get this kind of hallucination
that there's some like
scary looking teeth mouth thing i was
like maybe that's the antidepressant
withdrawal and that's just how it's
manifesting and if you look at medical
literature you can see visual
disturbances in antidepressant
withdrawal but like that happened you
know 10 times so i was seeing like
demonic faces
and then i've
had experiences where
i've also felt
you know like a sense of peace that
didn't seem
logical so it goes in in both directions
and at some point like i said in august
i was like you know what
maybe just maybe it's just god maybe uh
maybe that's the most logical
explanation for
um
for my life and so i don't know
it's it's strange because like i said
i've grown up my entire life being very
logical so i'm like yeah this is i know
i think that kind of talking about that
whole pain and growth thing
my experience has been that the more
painful things i experience which you've
experienced a lot of painful things the
more it kind of breaks me open to the
other side of joy and bliss and
happiness and
so you know
more and more
recently i have those moments of like
overwhelming joy that come and i could
yeah almost nothing like i might be just
be walking the dogs and i look at like
the moss on the side of the road that's
so beautiful and i'm just like
you know like and you just have this
like overwhelming joy and like
love like the love wave comes over
you're just like this is so nice and
like you think nothing else really
matters and you just sort of like have
these rose-colored lenses on for for a
little bit it doesn't last it's not like
i all of a sudden spend the rest of my
day there it'd be amazing but it does
not happen but these moments of waves of
joy and i think it's because the more
you
the more you break open to one side the
more you realize the other the more you
can feel the other side
and it's in i used to think that the
experience of life was about duality and
experiencing that
and what i realized is that it's
actually like in the duality helps me
realize the oneness because one has the
other one one
one action has a reaction you know so
you get this perspective that man it's
all it's all connected it's more of a
circle than it's a then it's an end of
the stick kind of thing
so when you experience something really
negative you're like okay well that
means there's something positive out
there to counteract this um i wouldn't
say it's direct it's not as though i per
have that perspective it's that i'm able
to access the emotions of joy and the
better the better emotions
a little bit um more often
they come they come
randomly it's not a
it's not a pain and then joy yeah and i
wonder if that's maybe some of it
because you've been through so much well
i definitely get that
for sure
something's gotta come from all the [ __ ]
like something's gotta come from the
pain right like it can't just be hard
yeah yeah no i i completely agree
i don't know but i i definitely i
definitely experienced that and i i
haven't been able to figure out what it
is either which is just like
it's exactly the same thing it's like
overwhelming love feeling and calm and
just like how is everything so good like
yeah everything's perfect everything's
perfect yeah i get that too it's very
strange i got that the first time
when i was 23 and that was when my when
i first started the diet my autoimmune
symptoms went away the depression went
away and i had that and it was just like
whoa i have never felt like this ever
before not even close
right and that was
yeah that was the first time and then i
didn't get it for a long time
2018 was good a lot there
i'm in good place now i don't know what
it is but i i understand that feeling
yeah yeah
um
i kind of want to shift into a little
bit of like having an opinion
and the repercussions of that
um
or the benefit of that like being a
being a disagreeable person
everybody should go ahead and take
you know her dad's personality test to
understand where you fall in the scope
of this but
being a disagreeable person
do you feel just as comfortable as ever
being disagreeable and having opinions
or do you not
does it or does the world get to you
no i'd say when i was
so i've gotten more vocal about
my opinions and more comfortable and
like i said before more
confident mm-hmm
and i i'd say that's just a
positive feedback loop like the the more
i wouldn't say have an opinion but the
more open i am with the opinion i'm open
to it changing too right like if i'm
wrong and i have if i have an opinion
and i'm wrong that's fine i would like
to know
where i'm wrong anyway so that
i'm not like living some sort of lie
right
so i'm open to learning but i say the
more um i talk about it the better i
feel because i used to especially when i
was younger and less
confident
uh i would have you know thoughts or
have and i'm sure this goes for a lot of
people you have thoughts and
have things you want to say but you're
not sure about how people will react or
whether or not you're wrong or if you're
going to offend somebody and it's like
okay maybe better to keep that to myself
but
i don't think that that makes it go away
right i don't think not saying something
makes it actually disappear
it's still out there i don't know if
it's out there in the form of energy or
if it's just trapped in you or something
but not saying things that you believe
in when you feel like you should say
them doesn't make them go away they just
get all stacked up inside you and then
you get
uncomfortable so i spent a long time not
saying and i was pr i've been pretty
vocal throughout my life like i haven't
been scared about
saying what i believe in but
you know i didn't say enough things i
think that i wanted to say that they
stacked up a bit
and
was like okay well that's not working
for me so i don't think it's negative at
all at least from the peace i'm
experiencing within myself yeah say
for people on the outside also it hasn't
really been negative i don't think
there's been any
anything negative about it i mean when i
first started talking about diet then
there was quite a bit of negativity
uh in the media about it but also i can
understand that you know it's an all
meat diet that sounds like crazy to most
people so it's like yeah there's gonna
be negativity so that didn't really
bother me
um i think the only time it's really
bothered me is if they've gone after my
dad or
yeah
the only time it's really bothered me
like there was an interview we did with
the times
and they went after my dad's like
and his acatheia
and that made me angry
right but that's like a pretty low blow
i think most people get angry if
somebody goes after a sick family member
you know other than that there really
hasn't been any negative
impact about
saying what i think
yeah i i i stand behind it i think it's
great
i thought that your interview with the
guy
recently
um i don't even want to say his name
because i don't really agree with his
perspective i don't really agree with
his vibe his message um
but you know you you you had someone on
your podcast that was
had said things about you that were
disrespectful
um
they weren't coming from direct
information they were perspectives they
were opinions and they were
you know turned into
click bait on the internet and um
first off i'm curious why you wanted to
have the conversation with somebody like
that that's kind of low blowing
a lot of the
issues he addressed like these
uh i don't know conspiracy theories on
the internet about my like personal life
he
basically in the video he made of me
he basically addressed all of them that
people have been bugging me about
since 2018.
so this has been going on for a while
right like and
normally i'm not bothered by things on
the internet but because my parents were
so ill and i was so st i was so stressed
out
um like i did i was doing primary care
for my dad for like a year and a half
which is brutal yeah and
during that time when there's also
conspiracy theories about me like
taking over his business or making him
sick in the first place like that was
like
and then you if you have a whole bunch
of people like yeah you know this blonde
ladies taking over a dad's business evil
you know behind the scenes person that
bugged me so i think the reason i had
him on was because i was like okay i'm
just gonna address like all these things
that people have said
over the last number of years and then
if anyone has an issue they can just go
to the
go to the episode and then we don't have
to have this conversation anymore
um so i thought about it because
and then and then the other part is i'd
actually invited him on
prior
to knowing that he'd actually gone after
me
about a week before
so
he'd already been invited on but i think
i would have invited him on anyway just
so i could address all these issues and
then
just not think about them anymore
because otherwise i had this part of me
that was like this needs to be addressed
somehow like i need to explain because i
can kind of see if you've got a really
negative perspective of the world and
you don't like women
and maybe you're not a very good person
i can understand how you could view
my family in that kind of light
and i was like i might as well just
address it i don't know if it like
changed it's not going to change in
anybody's mind that has their mind made
up already but it made me feel better
good you that's i mean i think that's a
good barometer of like am i doing this
for me or am i doing this for somebody
else or some something else and if you
feel better that's oh yeah i feel way
better yeah i'm really glad that's done
though
kind of disappointed that he got your
air time for like his platform which is
nothing compared to a lot of people
um yeah
and
his views were just you know it's like
almost like the negative attention got
him what he wanted attention like the
negative stuff got him attention
that he was looking for it's like you
know when somebody like stomps their
feet and they're like you know they want
attention for that it's not good
attention but it's attention you know
kind of got what he wanted like i the
one thing i said that one thing he said
that i thought was just so ridiculous
was when he said um
uh
29 to 31 if you're 29 to 31 years old as
a woman you just can't compete in the
sexual marketplace anymore and i was
like
what
i mean every woman out there has got to
be listening i mean being 39 i'm like so
like i'm nothing you know
and i thought that some of his
perspectives were just so
chauvinistic and
you know they were just tough and i i
kind of wonder why you didn't get i kind
of wonder why you weren't more mad at
him like i was like
come on
it wasn't worth it
like it just wasn't worth it i was mad
like i was i was not happy during that
entire podcast
like like
i was i don't know if i was angry i'm
just like tired more like it was just
tiresome but there wasn't
i don't know if there was a point
of arguing like he he's he believes one
thing about women and that is what he
believes and like i would say most
people who watch his stuff believe that
and i don't know like if i argue with
him it's just gonna prove their point
that women are like vindictive angry
you know
people that
are emotional and can't
i don't know what they think but i was
like i figured if i just let him talk
he'd show everybody what he was like
anyway which i think he did i think
that's actually a really good point
because i definitely got that impression
and i left the impress i left that i
mean the impression was this guy has got
ridiculous things that he's saying and
you know to say something like that i
thought dude that's a you problem that's
not a woman problem that's not a how old
are you how do you just turn 30 that's
not you're not less in the sexual
marketplace i'm 39 i'm not less in the
sexual marketplace because we're both
successful we're both smart we're both
attractive we're both ambitious we're
both young and take care of ourselves
like
what
i think i'm better in the sexual
marketplace than i used to be thank god
yeah you know
so i was like man that is a you problem
and i think that you know um for someone
to have such you know such distorted
perspectives i think it still shows that
there is an aspect of reality and uh of
culture
that believes something like that and
you know that's kind of where i think
guys get a bad name of the patriarchal
perspective or um chauvinistic i think
that's where that comes from when
there's that lack of open-mindedness and
such
ridiculous comments said and i think he
represents that i think he represents
that aspect of culture that still exists
perfectly perfect representation of that
yeah i know it was but that's such a
tiny percentage of people
right would you think
well i was a girl race car driver so i
probably got a little bit more of that
perspective
you know i don't i do i think it's a
tiny perspective um in certain cultures
and places but i don't think it's tiny
if we're looking at a macro
i mean there's still cultures in that
there's still cultures in the world
where women can't show their face or
body you know i mean there's still
i mean there's those still exist so
you know that's seemingly worse than
worse than this then
um so i think that i think that there
are a lot of men that
i think they're just hanging on to some
kind of power
i think that the true power i think the
true
revolution of our culture comes when men
and women both understand that there are
just things that each other does better
and like helps each other do them
yeah
no that's that's exactly right i mean
i've noticed that i think i've noticed
it a bit
running my dad's business because one
i'm his daughter so i'm you know there's
automatically this view of me like okay
well she's there because she's hurt his
daughter which like to be fair that's a
huge part of it
but a lot of it's because i can
communicate with my dad really
effectively because he's my dad um but
i definitely like when i'm in business
negotiations it's a lot easier even if
i'm doing the negotiation to say yeah
this is what my dad wants
right and then it's a completely
different argument which i'm fine with
doing because it's more effective and
i've kind of i think gotten through the
frustration and
not being taken as seriously because i'm
like okay i kind of get it right like
i'm the daughter of somebody you know
i've got blonde hair
i'm cute which i'm happy with i'd rather
be cute than not cute but like i can
kind of see how that comes off as
you know and i'm not taking this
seriously but how do i kind of use this
to my advantage and just work with it uh
so
yeah
yeah there's definitely an issue there
um being taken seriously i think as a
woman in the business world that's what
i've experienced anyway but
i've also worked around it so i'm not
sure i think there are probably
downsides
of things for everybody right
true absolutely
if we're talking about the the poll that
then becomes the circle like of course
yeah i mean there's
there's there's the pros and cons to all
of it for sure
um
yeah i found that interview fascinating
and i i think that you shed some light
on a good perspective of sometimes you
got to let people dig their own holes
yeah which is like yeah it was painful
though i'm not gonna lie about that i
was like oh
this is awful like that was awful yeah
but i was just trying to like listen and
be like is there something i'm missing
here
anyway
usually i can like oh
it was awful but i'm really glad i did
it like i'm really glad it's out um plus
then i can ignore all that because
anybody who
if anyone goes
like
after me dramatically right and they
know all the information and they're
still doing it there's nothing i can do
about it anyway so they might as well be
ignored you know makes me think of
what his parents were like
right makes you wonder kind of
this kind of gonna sort of lead into
raising kids and i you know you have a
daughter um
but i wonder like what were them what
was the modeling that someone would have
a perspective
we're just talking about one perspective
that a woman after 29 years old is
worthless for in the sexual marketplace
which means as a
mother or a wife probably or something
like that i'm kind of drawing some
conclusions
um but to be be able to say that and
have that perspective it kind of makes
me wonder what was like it doesn't
actually it makes me realize that his
parents perspective or at least his dads
probably
was that
right because we kind of follow in those
footsteps that becomes our modeling
and then i think about like communities
and how kids used to be raised more in
communities and there used to be more
grandparents around and elders and
nieces and nephews and everybody live
close to each other and that's just not
the reality anymore like the world is
we're all connected through
you know our phone we're connected
through our computer we're all just
connected and we can be anywhere and i
think it sort of takes away from that um
family aspect that used to exist so much
and i'm wondering if you think that this
is a this is a negative
culturally that we are not
in those communities where
kids learn lessons from
grandparents when there's multiple
people watching them where they can
learn things from and and it's a faster
learning process and a more i don't know
i would think you'd have to adapt a lot
more as a kid than just your one
patterned environment with your mom and
your dad or you're maybe just one parent
which a lot of times that's the case
um or if you think it's a better
direction that we're in where we're
connected with all this technology or if
we can even bridge the gap and come back
with all of it yikes
i'd say it's a huge loss right because
well like you said if you're raised by
one person you grow up yeah learning
everything from one person
i would assume that a larger group of
people raising a kid you'd be able to
identify oh people actually disagree too
you know grandma says this but my aunt
says this
right and i love them both you know type
of thing um i'd say it i'd say the
biggest i don't even know if it's just
for the kid but as like
as a mom
it was really hard for me because i
didn't have
like a community of people to help
so it's like you know like there are
people now they're like oh i can't raise
a kid it's like nobody used to be the
one raising a kid like no wonder people
are scared of raising kids even if it's
like a couple trying to raise a kid
that's hard like that's hard you're not
gonna sleep right and you like if you
don't have help and you're isolated like
no wonder you're scared people didn't
used to do that they used to have you
know like you said their sister or their
brother who already had four kids and
you know they're going uh relax it'll be
fine like have a glass of wine it's not
the end of the world instead of just
being isolated at home being like how do
i keep this alive
you know my friends are partying like my
parents live across the country right
like no wonder people are worried about
having kids it's ridiculous right now uh
i don't think there's any
i mean maybe there's a little bit going
back like maybe if people
change their mind about
kids being a hindrance
then maybe that could be reversed a
little bit if people started having more
kids
but
i don't know if that's gonna happen and
then with technology there's no getting
rid of that right and like i've got i've
got an aunt and uncle and they're in
silicon valley
and my uncle's like been at
apple and intel and everything and they
raised their kids without electronics
for a while but for long enough that it
actually
i think probably was a negative because
all the other kids knew
what they were doing so it's not like
you can isolate your kids from
technology without alienating them so
we're not getting rid of technology
unless you want to alienate your kids
and
i don't know it looks like we're
becoming more and more isolated
yeah community is a foundational element
if we're looking at ourselves as
um you know we can look at a human as a
cell and look at like you know cancer
and things like that come from a lack of
cell communication like we're the macro
version of the micro like we need
community it's foundational to our
existence that we're meant to be in
community and the communities that we're
in i mean the community of the family
gets smaller and then we just kind of
get into um a repeating loop usually we
we probably more so
find ourselves in these self-affirming
loops of people that are just like us
and so therefore the perspectives
continue to to separate more and more
because you are not in a family where
you're kind of forced to deal with
everyone and write and grandma and
grandpa looked at things differently and
aunts and uncles or kids and parents now
we're just like we're in this we're
we're in this affirming feedback loop
yeah and social media and technology
certainly doesn't help that because
you're like oh you can just go online
and find anybody who agrees with you oh
and well i mean the algorithms are
projecting more yeah
you know what you know this is what you
like right and they give you more and
they give you more and like it's not you
just continue to go down rabbit holes of
perspective and i think that you know
that's super dangerous i mean i think
there can be some actually what are the
positives and negatives of social and of
the of technology because look like it's
they're they're out there and there's a
lot of things that come from it but man
it's
is it at the cost of humanity
i hope not it's it's interesting like
some of these things like fringe ideas
right you'd say one of the negatives is
you know social media breeds into these
fringe ideas so
you can believe in some
insane conspiracy theory and you can
find a whole bunch of other people even
if it's just a thousand other people
that agree with you and then it's like
everybody believes that to you right but
then one of the benefits is also belief
in fringe
conspiracy theories
right because like even this even with
pale the paleo diet which most people
are familiar with now or the keto diet
and there's clear
there are clear
benefits
in regards to some things for like keto
diet for instance is proven to help
epilepsy and that's just in the medical
literature right
um those kind of diets have a way easier
time taking off because of social media
so some of those things have flourished
and those aren't bad things so
i don't know it's so tricky and we can't
change it anyway so we just have to
figure out how to adapt
well what are your rules for yourself
then i mean in trying to navigate and
keep your sanity and raising a daughter
and i mean it's a different and
different
different reality than it used to be
decades ago
um if i'm stuck in some sort of echo
chamber i try and expose myself to the
opposite of whatever anybody's thinking
so that's part of the reason for
opposing views too is because i'm i'm
definitely with a more conservative
crowd and i'm living in nashville so i
can get used to hearing the same ideas
we're just like okay even if it's kind
of painful for me to hear
an idea that i'm like
fairly firmly sold on the opposite of
that like i'll at least expose myself
and talk to some people who believe that
and try to understand and recognize when
i'm starting to hear the same thing over
and over and over again in regards to
scarlet and social media
i haven't really figured out how to do
that
at all and she's not old enough to
for that to be like a huge concern it's
not i don't know when that becomes a
huge concern but i would assume fairly
long young
nowadays like probably before you're a
teenager maybe like i don't know when so
i don't know how to deal with social
media probably at all sure
kids go to school that's like great as
soon as they're at school they kind of
have a phone so if their you know
parents are late they can text or they
can let them know something i mean it's
like how old is scarlett
four and a half
and she goes to school and
she'll be in first grade kindergarten
later next year yeah
uh
yeah i'm sure she knows how to work your
phone i think phones she knows youtube
too i
it's crazy like i didn't show her
screens for a long time so the first
couple years like i really was
i don't know i was just like that's bad
for some reason so i didn't show her
screens for a long time but then she
must have learned how to use youtube
in like in a ridiculous amount of time
even skipping ads and things and you're
like
what you didn't even really read right
like how does she use no you can't she
like just press press press and i was
like this is
yeah this is my theory that's intuitive
they were totally developed by kids
because it's following like you know uh
like natural cognitive motion patterns
and
instincts because they just know how to
use it so easily you're going on tour
with your dad
um
are you nervous
i might be nervous before the first show
i don't get very nervous
but i'm just doing the intro and the q a
so it's just like opening on stage for
20 minutes and then asking questions at
the end so it shouldn't be that tricky
but i'm excited it's really nice to be
with my family when everyone's healthy
look at it like
it was
really rare and unique or and really
beneficial or do you look at it now and
think wow
those things were not necessarily things
that kids normally talk about
or both i didn't i didn't realize that
it was weird until i was about 24 and
people started telling me it was weird
um but it was definitely beneficial and
i think because i was like chronically
ill
i think it was more beneficial because i
could have been raised in a home that
was just
well i just got felt sorry for kind of
and that wasn't the case at all it was
like i mean if anything i was pushed in
the other direction too much but then
here i am so was it too much i don't
know but
i'm extremely grateful for how i was
raised for whatever reason i really
believe i can accomplish things
and so i assume that's partly because of
how i was raised right that you know
fight back
yeah and do what you can and i think
that was instilled in me from my dad at
a young age which is don't let your
illness define you like no matter what
was there ever a point in time with your
illness and your dad and his work and
working with patients and
was there ever
ever a thought that anything was
psychological was that ever a point of
contention or a
an idea
oh well i mean i was diagnosed with
major depressive disorder when i was in
grade six so
yeah there was definitely uh
this is a psychological problem but i
mean i had arthritis so badly i had my
hip and ankle replaced when i was 17. so
those were clearly delineated problems
there was just like you've got major
depressive disorder so does dad so did
my grandpa so it was like you have this
generational thing and that's a you know
disorder you have chronic fatigue
because that was a disorder you've got
the arthritis so they were pretty
delineated
but there was definitely a psychological
component there was never the the only
part that kind of got conflated i would
say was when i had chronic fatigue
i was it was that was awful
i could barely get out of bed and a lot
of that was maybe you're not trying hard
enough and it turned out that wasn't the
case at all because now i don't have
chronic fatigue and it's not like i lay
around at all ever
so those two kind of got conflated but i
mean i think that happens unfortunately
a lot when people are sick which is like
how hard do you push them and what part
of them is just what if part of this is
just them whining or laziness and it
turns out
only usually none
but
it happens
none meaning not
usually sick people who are whining
about being sick usually
are actually sick right and that's why
they're being whiny about it
yeah so you think so you're then it's a
hundred percent a physical thing and
other than the
depression i mean i think that was
physical too because
as soon as my like inflammation as soon
as the arthritis went away and the
chronic fatigue the depression lifted so
it was all the same thing it was just my
body was not happy
for whatever reason with what i was
eating like really not happy
and that just manifested in different
symptoms so fatigue depression arthritis
but it was all you know my body not
being happy so so
you're definitely then i would think
believe that diet can help with
depression too
even 100 percent
one 100 yeah and i never believed that
at all until it happened to me right i
thought that you could have a serotonin
imbalance right that's what i was told
and that that's genetic and you're stuck
with it but that's not what i believe
anymore at all unless something
traumatic has happened to you like if
you just went through something
traumatic you can be depressed
yeah right but if you're depressed and
your life is fine you should probably
start start looking at diet or lifestyle
yeah
i mean even when you look at photos of
what people used to look at look like
decades ago you know there was generally
like reasonably fit people like maybe
they weren't muscular
or thin
they were thinner you know they kind of
had natural straight builds they weren't
bulky clunky obese like they were
generally and like you got to look at
the food like you got to look at the
sick care system you got to look at food
you got to look at what they put in it
and you gotta look at what they're what
people are eating and for the most part
you know people aren't eating real food
yeah it's crazy in america in particular
it's crazy and they make the worst of
the food the cheapest
which is a perpetuating problem without
money
yeah yeah no it's it's a
it's that's an epidemic for sure that
needs to be resolved or it's just
getting worse and worse and worse and
worse it's really sad and that that's
the same thing with like mental health
across the country people are getting
more and more depressed and more
mentally ill one in five people are on a
psych med and psych meds are almost
impossible to get off of how are you
going to solve that problem
well between opiates and psych meds
we're
we're not doing so well
no no
earth and everything on it is
struggling you know you've described
yourself as like someone that's in a has
an obsessive need for more and you like
really you're always wanting to squeeze
more out and do more and so what's that
more like what's the next thing what's
the what do you what are you calling in
what do you let's talk let's use your
mom's lingo like what are you calling in
what are you manifesting or maybe
praying for
okay well these are things that are
actually in the works already we're
working on something called peterson
academy
and so we have like top experts
in their field in humanities and social
sciences we're going to be filming
courses similar to my dad's personality
course so like lecture style courses and
putting them on this peterson academy
platform and trying to take on the
universities provide people with content
that's
not ideological
and that's fascinating from top
professors you know
all over the world we have a bunch of
cambridge professors lined up
so
that is massive i'm really excited about
that i think it's going to be huge
that hopefully is launching in the fall
so that's the main thing i'm going to be
working on i'm finishing my book i have
a couple of products coming out
so i've won
this is crazy too then it works i swear
it works but i'm i'm calling it after
party and it's
dihydromyricitin which can be used for
hangovers
not that i drink but i used to drink a
lot and i used to use this anyway um we
we have a mixture maybe it it works
fantastically well i'll have to get
better at marketing it instead of just
being like believe me but anyway that's
in the future i have electrolytes coming
out and then there's the tour and
everything but what am i manifesting i
really like more kids so how i somehow
squish that in at the same time talk me
into it i have i don't have kids in 39
why should i have kids i've never
experienced more love for anything than
having a kid
so like i don't know what i would love
more than
like babies i don't know i would like
plus then what are you gonna do when
you're old
i mean you could do business forever but
don't you wanna like see
like
people running around and have people
over for christmas and things and like
watch
them grow up and then
they have kids and you have grandkids
i don't know if there's anything better
than that and i'm pretty motivated by
like business and money and opportunity
but but i think that there's a way i if
you're you know smart and productive i
think that there's a way that you can do
it all right you have to take time off
when you have a kid
um but
i mean i'm certainly not gonna be
stay-at-home mom
and just put my life on hold right but i
think that i can i think i can do it all
so if i could do that i would like that
sometimes what are you willing to
sacrifice what is your what's on the ch
what comes first on the chopping block
sacrifice wise to
make space for for this new thing you're
calling in for kids
um well i think what i would do is once
i got pregnant is i would start
delegating like mad so i'd have like 10
months to continue
keeping everything running and maybe
hire somebody and just delegate and
delegate and delegate well i'm sure that
you know based on your mom
and praying or meditating or whatever
you want to call it i you know i call it
manifesting um i'm sure you're going to
call in all those things so um thanks
for taking the time and your
perspectives and i really love to hear
them and you're you're a really
interesting person to listen to and
don't forget about those opposing views
come on
yes okay thank you so much that was
really fun it was lovely meeting you all
right nice to meet you too thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today i hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the subscribe button